mornings
i wake up every morning at nine and grab
for the morning paper then i look at the
obituary page if my name's not on it i
get up benjamin franklin
i'm not a morning person
i'm not the guy who hits the snooze
button six times and wants to stay in
bed all day i actually don't use an
alarm more on that later
but i don't usually wake up super
motivated and ready to take on the day
it takes me a while to get started
struggle
i used to struggle with this a lot i saw
successful entrepreneurs and it looked
like they were always on it looked like
they never doubted themselves or had
days when they weren't motivated
i worried that if i wasn't super
motivated like them i wouldn't get the
success i was after
why wasn't i just naturally motivated
every morning what's wrong with me
so i looked for motivational videos to
watch when i woke up
and it worked
for a while
the problem was if you watch the same
video over and over again it stops
becoming as motivational
at least that was the case for me
highs and lows
i couldn't understand how i could have a
great day yesterday be on top of the
world feel so motivated and passionate
and then wake up the next morning and
have to start from scratch
like yesterday didn't even happen
the feeling of excitement and motivation
just disappeared and i had to start all
over again
i wasn't depressed or sad
i just wasn't super motivated
i was a bit lazy and slow
routine
after a lot of searching and struggling
i finally found something that worked
for me
create a daily morning routine that
inspires you
my routine evolves as i evolve but if
you can create a routine that serves you
it's a great way to kick start your day
and get you ready for action
here's what my morning routine looks
like right now
eight to nine am wake up
i don't set an alarm i prefer to wake up
naturally
so i don't wake up at the same time
every day i wake up when i wake up
forcing an early wake-up time and being
tired all day especially after a night
of salsa dancing doesn't seem like a
winning strategy to me
9-9 30 am
breakfast and social
first thing i do is go to the kitchen
and drink a large glass of water
when you wake up your body is dehydrated
from a night's sleep and needs water
there are also a number of health
benefits to having water first thing in
the morning that i won't go into here
google it
i'll grab my breakfast which usually
consists of spinach lentils and two cut
up hot dogs
starting the day with protein is another
amazing life hack
but here's the key
over breakfast i'll check my social
media comments and engage with my
audience you guys
i love doing this because the comments
are always overwhelmingly positive and
it starts to get me motivated and wake
me up
for example here's one that came in this
morning on youtube wow great advice evan
p.s i discovered your channel yesterday
and it's still shocking how you're not
trying to sell yourself and you always
give away so many valuable tips others
would charge hundreds for
i think i know who my dream mentor would
be
i get these every day
how can you not get motivated reading
comments like that
9 30 to 10 a.m weights
next i'll do a quick workout
i find that by physically being active
my mind starts to get active as well
i'll usually work out while watching
sports highlights from yesterday and
thinking about some of the comments
people left for me
seeing athletes push themselves on tv
makes me push myself harder in my
workout
i'll finish with another glass of water
and a protein shake then come back to
the computer to finish up any remaining
social media comments
10 to 10 30 am cardio
up next is a 30 minute run
i put my headphones on load up some
youtube videos on my laptop and start
running on the spot
i watch videos that will make me think
videos that challenge me to change
right now some of my favorite ones are
by jonathan fields and eric thomas go
look them up
i give a thumbs up and usually a comment
on the ones that i like
to find new ones i find the youtube what
to watch videos does a pretty good job
in suggesting interesting clips to watch
based on my past history
10 30 to 11 am shower get ready
i then hop in the shower and think about
everything i learned so far i think
about the social media comments and the
new videos i just watched i think about
how i can apply it to my business and
what i want to accomplish today i find a
lot of great thoughts come to me in the
shower
and especially after being hit with so
much positive information
11 to 11 45 am miscellaneous
this is an open time slot for me that i
feel with various activities on
wednesdays i have media training that
goes through the whole time on tuesdays
and fridays i have a call with my agent
that usually lasts for 15 minutes
every second thursday i have my radio
show
in the extra time i have i'll fill it
with whatever inspired me usually an
idea that came from the shower
11 45 am leave
i usually leave at 11 45 to get to the
office for noon
you start at noon
this is a common response when i tell
people about my schedule and yes i start
at noon i also leave at 3 15 to go pick
up my son from school and hang out with
him
three hours of solid work with a 15
minute break in between
but my mornings are when i do a lot of
my real work the hard work the thinking
creative future direction of the
business work you don't get your best
ideas when you're stressed out not
sleeping not taking care of yourself
working 18 hours a day
you get it when you're relaxed when
you're active when you're in the shower
when you're inspired by someone or
something
so i give myself all of those things
every day to give me the best chance of
success
and i turn my mornings from being the
worst to being the best part of my day
your turn
believe